[Music]
right here with reaction to all of
today's breaking news he's the host of
the number one show sunday nights 10
eastern life liberty levin
right here on the fox news channel host
of crtv's levin tv we call him the great
one for a reason mark levin
all right mark i mean there are some
lessons here i i agree that you
shouldn't lie to the fbi
everyone agrees with that i also agree
that you should pay your taxes
i also agree that you better not lie in
a bank loan application
mark how did we get from russia
and that this is it after nearly we're
almost at 500 days
all right i want to address michael
cohen how did we get to that
i want to help the law professors the
constitutional experts the criminal
defense lawyers the former prosecutors
and of course the professors
i want to help them understand what the
law is the general counsel for the
clinton mob family lanny davis he had
his
client plead the two counts of
criminality that don't exist
these campaign finance violations that
all over tv
they're saying implicates the president
of the united states directly
first let's back up it is a guilty plea
it is a plea bargain between a
prosecutor and a criminal
a criminal who doesn't want to spend the
rest of his life in prison
that is not precedent that applies only
to that specific case nobody cites
plea bargains for president that's
number one
number two just because a prosecutor
says
that somebody violated the campaign law
doesn't make it
so he's not the judge he's not the jury
we didn't adjudicate
anything it never went to court that's
number two
a campaign expenditure under our federal
uh campaign laws
is an expenditure solely for campaign
activity
a candidate who spends his own money or
even corporate money
for an event that occurred not as a
result of the campaign
it is not a campaign expenditure let me
give a few examples
to help people understand this
especially the american people let's say
i wrote these down
let's say a candidate had said we owe
vendors a whole lot of money we've had
disputes with them
but i want you to go ahead and pay them
i'm a candidate i don't want all this
negative publicity
so he says to his private lawyer you pay
them i'll reimburse you
get it done is that illegal it's
perfectly legal
yet according to the prosecution of the
southern district of new york
it's paid at the direction of the
candidate to influence an election
yes mr prosecutor how stupid is your
point
it's not a crime more let's say
this candidate settles a lawsuit that
was initiated before he becomes a
a candidate and he says to his his
personal lawyer
i want you to pay settle that lawsuit
you can use my corporate funds my
private funds whatever it is
that is perfectly legal too the
prosecutor would say
but that influenced the election so what
there are certain things you do that
influence an election that are legal
certain things you do that influence an
election later illegal let's say a
candidate
uh gets a non-disclosure agreement from
a disgruntled employee wants to quiet
that disgruntled employee
as he goes into the election he pays the
funds out of his pocket or through his
corporation
perfectly legal nothing here was spent
out of the campaign
nothing was done with the campaign or to
the campaign
this is exactly what the federal law is
and mr lanny davis had his client
plead guilty to two offenses that aren't
offenses
that the prosecutor insisted were
offenses
that's why he's no good that is michael
cohen
against donald trump donald trump's in
the clear let's say donald trump even
directed michael cohen to make payments
in non-disclosure agreements so what
he's allowed to do that now
here's my question has the southern
district of new york ever paid
money in a non-disclosure agreement with
any of its employees how about any u.s
attorney's office in the united states
how about the department of justice how
about any business
how about any union how about the dnc
how about members of congress
it's done all the time but call it hush
money
and all of us hush money oh they can't
pay hush money
well it is hush money it's legal it's a
contract it's done
all the time now what does mr mueller
have left
it's worked he's chasing the manhattan
madam who the hell's the manhattan man
i don't know how he's interviewing he's
dragging her in front of the grand jury
what's next the manhattan madam he's got
he's got manafort where he wants him on
on banking charges uh he set up a few
guys like flynn
who's gotten in trouble now they have
cohen
what do they have they have nothing i'll
tell you what they have
mr mueller as a federal prosecutor
is preparing his impeachment report
which is an unconstitutional activity mr
mueller is supposed to be non-political
he's not supposed to be preparing
impeachment reports mr mueller i told
you before
you can't indict a sitting president i
told you that 15 months ago
now you figured it out you and
rosenstein figured it out
now you and rosenstein are trying to
figure out what to do with the subpoena
you see sean
giuliani was on your show the other day
or somebody show he said why do they
take two or three weeks i'll tell you
why they take two or three weeks
because mr mueller has to consult mr
rosenstein his boss
to figure out what to do with this
subpoena i'll tell you what happens when
they issue that subpoena
the president of the united states takes
it all the way to the supreme court and
what does he cite
department of justice memos what else
does he cite
the constitution of the united states so
this is going to be an impeachment
battle in the end
the president of the united states if he
doesn't get involved in the
perjury trap think about that they don't
have a crime
he needs this interview to create a
crime against the president of the
united states this prosecutor
well that's pretty damn outrageous so in
any event
i want the news media to understand you
know what took place in the southern
district of new york
nothing that matters there was no
violation of federal campaign laws
lanny davis blew it lanny davis lanny
davis he's puts out a tweet today
today cohen stood up and testified under
oath that donald trump directed him to
commit a crime
you're a dummy lanny by making payments
to two women for the principal purpose
of influencing an election
if those payments were a crime for
michael cohen then why would they be a
crime for donald trump
they weren't a crime for michael cohen
he screwed himself
and they're not a crime for donald trump
either now move along and go back into
your corner with hillary clinton
but well obviously he's a huge clinton
sycophant um
so this 2016 campaign with what 77 days
out
is now becoming as i have said for a
long time
it's about impeachment keeping obamacare
them wanting their crumbs back
eliminating ice open borders and
stopping
the investigation into what i say is the
biggest abuse of power here's what i
want to ask you
so we now have hillary rodham clinton
obstructing
violating the espionage act no
indictment we now have her paying for
what turns out to be a foreign entity a
foreign agent
putting together russian lies that are
disseminated to the american people
to influence an election lies never
verified
never corroborated then put as the bulk
of information and four fisa warrants
comey sally yates rod rosenstein they
all signed off and they all said
they swore they put their their good
name and credibility behind it
i don't see comey indicted i don't see
any i don't see
any hillary clinton indictments i don't
see
any crimes that are being pursued here
barack obama had what two million
dollars in campaign finance violations
he just paid
can i interrupt for a second yeah go
ahead interrupt on my own show
the head of the fbi is not the head of
the fbi anymore he's a confessed leader
and he's under investigation by the
inspector general the deputy
fbi director was fired and is under
criminal investigation mr stroke
who was the head counterintelligence
investigator was fired and he's under
investigation i believe
or will be or should be under
investigation as well
that's the top tier of the federal
bureau of investigation i've never heard
of anything like this before
you have a mole in the deputy attorney
general's office who's working with
stroke who's been fired
his wife works for the fusion gps
pushing out the opposition research
against the president of the united
states getting it in front of the fisa
court through the fbi
bruce ohr bruce ohr who served for the
deputy attorney general of the united
states and there's
there's tons more you have fisa court
judges that have never been held to
account
fraud you had an application that was
filed with the fisa court
they didn't say who paid for the
opposition research that was used
to to violate their rules yeah we need a
special counsel
now for that you know some great smart
constitutional lawyer once wrote a book
and in the book he said this is a
post-constitutional america
oh that was you we're there